was westworld's man in black a host
throughout season two what was the
island on lost and which game of thrones
character got a shorter end of the
writing stick than daenerys targaryen
keep watching to find out
for six seasons sopranos had audiences
glued to their tv screens with its
ongoing depiction of the life and times
of new jersey mob boss tony soprano for
the uninitiated it's often hailed as the
greatest show of all time however the
final episode of the sopranos made in
america had audiences screaming at their
television in the series final scene
tony waits for his family to gather for
dinner in a diner as each family member
trickles in the camera takes tony's
perspective and begins to linger on
suspicious looking men entering the
diner as well as the scene unfolds the
background music swells to a crescendo
resulting in a palpable sense of dread
then the screen cuts to black before
credits roll at the time viewers
believed their cable had cut out during
the show's pivotal moment in the 15
years since its closing moments fans
debated if the cut to black meant tony
was alive or dead the debate seemed
endless until a 2021 interview between
series creator david chase and the
hollywood reporter in the interview
chase explained he always intended for
the show to end with tony's death he
also said that he felt the finale didn't
need to show the death while the
sopranos will always be remembered for
ambiguous storytelling at least the
debate over tony's death is finally
sleeping with the fishes wipe it through
it changes the way you think
hbo's west world and its story of ai
theme park hosts revolting against their
human overlords has riveted audiences
and sometimes been hard to understand
show creators jonathan nolan and lisa
joy built their story like a
well-crafted maze featuring different
timelines and twists galore more often
than not the show addresses most
questions by a given season's end
however one thread has been hanging
since the season 2 finale post-credit
stinger the scene depicts series heavy
william also known as the man in black
being administered a fidelity test by
his daughter before cutting to black the
scene was misunderstood for two reasons
the first is because william killed his
daughter earlier in season two the
second is because fidelity tests are a
method for testing the accuracy of
robotic copies of humans but the
audience never witnessed the arrival of
william's synthetic doppelganger the
stinger threw the entirety of williams
season 2 arc into question and left fans
to wonder if william had actually been a
host throughout the whole season to make
things more confusing william returns as
the human antagonist in season 3 until
he's killed by his robot copy in the
season 3 finale so now audiences know
who's who but there's still no
explanation for the scene following the
close of season 2. in 2018 joy told the
hollywood reporter the season 2 stinger
takes place far in the future of the
show here's hoping we finally get
answers in season four
everything we've done
in the 2000s lost followed the marooned
oceanic flight 815 crash survivor's
attempts to survive on a mysterious
island it was an enormous hit however
when the finale aired in may of 2010
most viewers left asking themselves one
question was the island purgatory in its
final scenes the show cuts between
alternate timelines in one timeline
series protagonist jack succumbs to his
wounds from a battle to save the world
in the other timeline the main
characters gather in a church to leave
for the afterlife together finally after
all of this buildup the show ended on a
lingering image of the original crash
site only it was completely deserted for
years fans suspected the final scenes
meant the show had been a metaphor for
purgatory for many the shot of the empty
crash site following jack's departure
for the afterlife with the other
survivors signaled the show was about
trapped souls fans also took this to
mean no one survived the initial crash
according to vulture showrunner damon
lindelof confirmed the island wasn't
purgatory and that the show's events had
all actually occurred as depicted
lindelof was concerned the impact of the
ending would be ruined if it was
followed by a commercial so he added the
last scene to give the audience a moment
with their emotions in the end the main
cast leaving for the next life together
highlighted the show's true focus the
ways people come together when they're
lost
for seven seasons audiences tuned in to
game of thrones for its unique brand of
high fantasy and dangerous politics the
show gave viewers plenty of interesting
characters to root for and against but
lord varus the ruthless spymaster with a
heart of gold proved especially
intriguing going into the final season
most assumed varys had a major role to
play in the endgame so when varys got
caught in an obvious plot to undermine
daenerys targaryen's ascension to the
throne and was executed for his betrayal
folks were stunned his plan send letters
containing information that would negate
daenerys claim to the throne in broad
daylight from a castle surrounded by
guards while varys stupid plan isn't
hard to understand and his death served
the greater plot the way it happened
seemed rushed to most fans according to
tinderbox by james andrew miller the
game of thrones book series author
george r.r martin was hoping the show
would last 10 seasons instead of eight
during interviews with martin and his
agent paul haas it was revealed that the
showrunners david benioff and d.b weiss
thought differently haas said that they
were done with the show and wanted to
move on so while fans may never know
exactly why the last season went the way
it did it's likely moments like ferris's
death were symptomatic of benioff and
weiss's desire to wrap it up check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]